public Israel is that prom with Israel
is it's basically a colonialist state
and it began that way in the 1800's by
1948 they were you had thirty percent of
the population who were Jews 70 percent
Arab it wasn't going to work and so a
lot of the Arabs were expelled by the
Zionists and the land grab has just kept
going and going and going
so at the beginning of the century Jews
owned seven percent of the land and then
after the partition in 47 they owned
they were given 56 percent of the land
and then they got 78 percent of the land
and now they're settling on the other 22
percent of the land so it's basically a
land grab and you can dress that land
grab out as a response to the Holocaust
Jews are unsafe in other parts of the
world but for me it's it's just that's
the problem it's a land grab and there's
a lack of respect for Palestinian human
rights
I wish that Americans understood more
the conditions under which Palestinians
are living in the West Bank and in Gaza
I think that if Americans saw this on in
the journey if the journalism was honest
about this they would be horrified and
they would say we cannot support the
Israeli government so unilaterally when
we look at the Iraq situation and we
look at suicide bombing in Iraq we say
that that has a political component that
it's a dispute over power and territory
oil and we don't say that it's just
religious or that it's fanatics and
extremism and I think that we should be
able to look at the palestinian
situation and while not excusing suicide
terrorism saying if your land had been
taken away from you on this consistent
basis for so long you also would be very
desperate and if walls were going around
if they were uprooting your olive trees
pouring raw sewage on your land
poisoning your goats you know you'd be
pretty P owed I mean the one theme I was
going to suggest it the one thing I
wanted to bring in is I think that
something very interesting is happening
right now in the Jewish community which
is that younger Jews are having a
different response to I mean I'm a
typical in my criticize I'm obviously a
harshly critical of Israel and I'm a
typical of American jewelry in that
attitude I don't hold myself forward as
being representative but what is
happening is that my attitude is more
widely shared among young Jews and that
is because older Jews my parents
generation which finds my my ideas very
upsetting grew up with 1948 with 67 70s
with these very heroic images of young
Israeli society in this making the
Desert Bloom and young Jews have grown
up with accusations of aparte which I
find subs well the accusations of
apartheid they see them around you know
they've seen the two Intifada
they've seen some level of palestinian
desperation they've and you know it's
not a fun cause for young Jews and I
think there's been a lot of defection my
sort of personal defection is one that
is there's a lot of alienation among
young Jews and this is a statement that
even official American jewelry would
agree with there's a crisis going on and
I went to AIPAC last week the the major
part of the Israel lobby and they're
very concerned about this they are
reaching out to others than Jews they
are spending a lot of money - I think
indoctrination Jews in this but the sort
of passionate belief in Israel that you
see at AIPAC it's a very moving actually
to see excuse me
to see older choose how these people are
they're spending tons of money on
another out of a generous impulse I mean
they truly are really concerned about
these people on the other part they're
not spending it on themselves they're
not you know they've all done well I
mean but they're they're spending it on
their try but they're just really
generous of these AIPAC people and
they're really concerned and but and
they love Israel I mean you just have to
hand it mean these things are genuine
and sincere and fervent but that feeling
is not sustained in young Jews and that
is a real crisis for those who support
Israel